en el centro cultural municipal de
paraná beach y galaxy es maestra ensaya
su nueva canción la escribimos la mañana
después de saber que no íbamos a ir a
eurovisión a las 11 de la mañana estaba
lista
[Música]
y el grupo fue elegido por la televisión
estatal de belarús para representar al
país en eurovisión pero su solicitud fue
rechazada por considerar la canción
demasiado política
[Música]
tú
para algunos fue una celebración de la
violencia policial contra los
manifestantes anti lukashenko el año
pasado
dimitri lo niega
es una buena canción ligera e irónica o
es que estos tipos son santos y no
podemos burlarnos de ellos según dmitri
a esta canción es solo una sátira de la
sociedad bielorrusa que sale demasiado
fácilmente a la calle en su opinión
ni siquiera esperaron los resultados
oficiales el mismo día en las elecciones
las plazas de la ciudad estaban repletas
de gente del curso exterior no podían
esperar a ver qué ocurría y tomar
decisiones mesuradas eso es lo que
criticamos
según las encuestas al igual que dmitri
muchos de los rusos no apoyan las
protestas
pero la mayoría está a favor
la movilización del pasado agosto no
tiene precedentes en los 26 años que
lleva a lukashenko en el poder pero ante
la represión policial
el movimiento se debilita en paraná
beach y siete meses después en los
patios de los edificios sólo quedan
algunos vestigios
el 25 de marzo los líderes de la
oposición intentaron reavivar el
espíritu de la protesta convocaron un
concierto de voces
poco seguido
porque según una nueva ley cualquier
toque de bocina injustificado puede
conllevar a la pérdida de la licencia
ese día la policía acordonó la capital
unas 200 personas fueron detenidas
manifestantes
a cualquiera que los estuviera grabando
e incluso simples transeúntes
antón no se aventuró a salir de su casa
no quiero arriesgarme a ir a protestar
en nombre de los que realmente necesitan
un cambio pero no se arriesgan a salir a
la calle los trabajadores de las
fábricas el pasado mes de agosto antonio
otros activistas les ofrecieron pagar
sus salarios si se unían al movimiento
y nos creyeron y dejaron las fábricas
pensé oh ya está hemos ganado y luego
todos volvieron a trabajar
durante cuatro meses antón estuvo en
todas las congregaciones y tiene buenos
recuerdos de hecho
de bella de román bondarenko fue dura
román bondarenko uno de los activistas
asesinados estuvimos orando en casa y
luego nos reunimos todos para llorar
juntos
creo que la mitad del país toma
antidepresivos pero no nos rendiremos
solo intentamos hacer y creer en un
futuro mejor pero si ahora mismo es muy
difícil
ante la represión algunas personas se
están encontrando otras formas de
oponerse al régimen
en la histórica ciudad de bam alude a
como cada semana se reúne este pequeño
grupo de activistas y escudriña a los
policías de los alrededores
hoy son dos pero la semana pasada habían
más de ellos que de nosotros éramos
quince y ellos son los veinte y nos
detuvieron a todos vieron que el centro
era un centro extremista eso fue lo que
dijeron y que saben por qué nos reunimos
aquí y que nos lo prohíben y que harán
cualquier cosa para detenerlos
y por qué se reúnen hacemos visitas
guiadas
frente a la cámara no nos dicen más
ese día el grupo llegó sin problemas a
las ruinas de un castillo del siglo 14
luego participó en un seminario sobre
desarrollo turístico
[Música]
a falta de una perspectiva política
estos opositores han encontrado nuevas
causas que defender a nivel local
aunque sus ambiciones sean por el
momento ciudadanas
la policía los vigila desde fuera